Hello Freak bitches.
What?
So how long have you been raising bees?
Probably only,
maybe four years.
What,
how'd you get started in that?
How do you start raising beings?
Start with one.
We'll actually start with to really
know,
um,
they're not like rabbits,
but they do produce quite quickly,
you know?
Uh,
my dad raised bees,
uh,
I just,
we always saw boxes out in the corner of
the house.
We grew up in la here and you know,
the weather's so great.
So there's lots of activity that's the
bummer about being unveiled now.
Not a lot of,
not a lot of b action going on.
It's too high.
It's too cold and certain vegetables
grow there,
but not a lot.
But uh,
in California,
the ranch love,
I love it.
I got it.
I had a friend who in his backyard,
he,
he probably had six hives and he had
this one really intense kind of rogue
hive where maybe the queen had some kind
of strain of it,
a africanized or something.
And her wife could not,
his wife could not go out in the
backyard without being attacked,
you know.
So he says,
Hey,
can I go put my bees on your property so
they can cycle this queen out,
you know,
they got some breeding in.
It was just off Jesus Christ.
So he,
he brought it out to the ranch,
he pinched the B and then a pinch.
The queen pinched it.
What do you mean killed it?
And then she's crying.
It's a nice euphemism.
You didn't have to shoot it or nothing.
Hold still.
So he just grabbed the queen and killed
her.
Well has pinched it could because she
was reproducing.
I mean they lay a million eggs in their
lives.
It's insane that,
I mean,
I,
I basically,
I could sit here and talk a whole hour
about bees because they're so
interesting.
Let's do it.
Alright,
well the listener,
I'm not scaring,
you know,
they'll listen.
They'll listen.
Trust me.
It's interesting stuff.
So yeah,
put it,
put a new queen in there.
And they,
they cycled through all of the other BS.
I mean they only live a month.
So what is a no,
so informal reaction when people go in
the yard would be,
they would just disinterest.
They wouldn't care about you as long as
you're not interrupting the hive.
Exactly.
But your wife would go out there and
they would just get crazy.
Yeah,
it was,
oh yeah,
this wasn't me.
This was my friends while.
That's right.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah,
I mean,
but he,
he's kind of used to it and she was not.
She was out to go swimming or go out
there and they would,
they would get crazy with him,
but he's like,
it just doesn't bother me.
But she was like,
fuck this queen.
Fuck this hive.
Yeah.
Pretty much.
And there are certain things if we're,
we're in black,
they all attack you.
They think you're a bear.
You know what's,
yeah,
uh,
if you've just eaten banana's,
there's some,
I don't know,
a smell or something in it that is
similar to their attack pheromone that
they set off.
So there's a few things I've learned
over the years.
Tony Bananas and don't,
don't wear black.
Exactly.
That's all you gotta do.
But I learned this stuff being in the
bee club.
You're in a prison.
I was in the bee club.
Yeah,
in,
uh,
in the bay area.
Yeah.
We'd meet down at the,
uh,
American Legion's Paul and have a
monthly meeting,
you know,
one of those dorks like me and my buddy.
Oh my God,
we would just sit there and kind of
laugh about them.
But we're sitting there,
we're here to learn some stuff.
But there were people up there that,
okay,
we inseminated the queen with this and
you know,
there were counting bs,
we put little numbers on every B and
we've caught their flight pattern and
how many were reproducing this.
And I mean it,
it's all,
you know,
it's all a,
like they're,
they're,
they're doing research on how to make
the stronger because the bees are going
away.
But,
um,
you know,
it's,
this might this little Varroa mite
that's killing a lot of them too,
along with the pesticides and
herbicides.
But,
uh,
you know,
people that are so into it and we're
just gonna sit in there going home,
man,
what have we gotten ourselves into?
But it's Kinda,
you know,
it's funny in a certain way,
but I'm glad that it's happening.
But uh,
you know,
I get it at the end of the season,
you get like 500 pounds of honey and
you're handing them out to your friends
and everyone's loving it.
Five hundred pounds of honey.
That's insane.
And we're bottling it up.
My kids are filtering it,
we're bottling it up and it,
dude,
it's just straight from the hive into a
bottle.
I mean,
after you filtered it and it really
helps with allergies.
It helps with,
uh,
you know,
the whatever,
getting the pollens and then nectars
from the area.
So when you take that in and it helps
build your immune system.
Yeah,
I've heard that.
So you've experienced that personally?
Absolutely.
And I think being stung by bees helps
you to,
it helps with,
with something getting your,
your immune system built up.
It's supposed to be really good for
arthritis.
They,
they take people like literally take
bees,
people that are,
that have serious arthritis in their
hands and they sting their hands.
Right.
That on purpose.
I think there's some people that do it
for their lips here in la.
Well,
I think you need people that are so
deep,
deep into the pe world because you're
not going to do it.
I'm not going to do it,
but if someone's just so far gone,
they're measuring all their bs and
monitoring their flight patterns and
checking their DNA.
I'm just fascinated that there was a
clear differentiation between a normal b
and the way these bees were behaving
that you could tell that the queen was
kind of a free.
But I tell you,
those freak beast,
the Africanized or whatever,
now there's a Zombie bee and we can,
we can get into that too.
But uh,
they are,
they are aggressive and an aggressive,
you know,
it's like any society,
they do well,
they,
they get most,
they produce a lot of honey and they,
they,
they're very,
very prolific in what they do,
you know?
Yeah.
I've had killer bee honey.
They make killer be like,
oh,
what sounded good on it?
I don't know if he knows any better.
If it's a killer bee honey is better
than regular honey,
but just pretty dope to have killer bee
honey around your house,
you know,
that.
And the uh,
uh,
Gosh.
Oh,
what's this stuff called?
I mean,
there's lots of really cool healing
properties in,
in like even the,
the,
the kind of glue that they use to plug
up holes and you know,
uh,
the Royal Jelly,
which is,
you know,
comes from there,
like the brain and it,
that's how they produce a queen.
I mean there.
So Royal Jelly is.
Yeah.
It's from their brains.
Brain juice,
man.
Holy Shit.
How does it come out as it come out of a
hole somewhere?
A,
what do they have to scoop it out of
their fucking heads?
I haven't seen it that close,
but
they injected into the,
injected,
into the queen cell or there's a cell
that they make when a new queen is being
made.
So all the bees that are flying around
that you see out here,
you know,
they're all females.
It's a huge,
it's all female society,
so the drones that are in there,
which are the males,
they're there just to reproduce and then
they get kicked out in the wintertime
and they all die.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Yeah,
man.
It's hard outside.
Brutal.
Brutal for us men in the B world.
So if they all die,
how do they continue to reproduce?
Well,
there's some,
I guess the couple stay on.
They,
they,
the queen makes more.
Wow.
So those guys are just dead.
The Queen makes more on the new ones.
Takeover the new boys.
Yeah.
And they're just doing work.
They're just there.
They're just fertilizing.
That's what they're doing.
They're just there to fuck.
And then everybody else is doing all the
real word fuck and go die.
That's what you get to do this brutal
world.
That's what a fucking crazy world.
And then the queen goes around the hive
and finds the females,
other,
other potential queens and stabs them
while they're in the hive.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
Well they're,
they're all females or all female except
for those drones.
And then if there's,
if they're making a,
you know,
she knows she's going to die or they're,
they're kind of pissed off with her.
She's not reproducing as much as she
should.
She will take off with like half the
hive and that's why you see a swarm.
So she'll go and form a new hive and
then these ones have a little queen cell
that they've laid eggs and start to make
a new queen.
So that's how they reproduce.
And if there's three or four queen cells
in there,
the first queen that's born,
she comes out and she kills all the
other Queens so she can rule game of
thrones type shit.
That's fascinating.
And you're going to get bs.
I can tell him I'm right now looking at
my head,
I'm just looking at websites in my hand.
I'm like trying to find out where to get
the bees.
Yeah,
that sounds like an amazing way to get
honey.
I mean it just sounds like a really cool
thing to do to a taste.
So good.
And we've got,
you know,
we,
we have a place in Hawaii,
so we've got Hawaiian flavored Hawaiian
flavored.
Well there's stuff,
you know,
that they,
they,
uh,
get the nectar and pollen from over
there and you know,
Hawaii's nonstop.
Yeah.
So you're getting honey year round.
What island and Maui.
Oh Man,
I love Maui.
That's a beautiful spot.
So when you,
how do you know that a b is Africanized?
Because that was the big thing that
everybody was worried about.
You remember it was like the early
nineties.
Everybody's like,
did we say,
found an African killer bee and no next
echo or something.
It was like,
it's coming up,
it's going to,
it's going to swarm.
They going to take over the country.
And inside of a few years there was a
big hysteria about that,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
and there are,
there are states where there are more
prevalent than others and they're just
more aggressive or more aggressive and
they're,
they're very protective.
So you'll get stung if you're messing
with them.
So that's all it is.
There's nothing so.
But we,
there was a big concern that they were
going to take over and that it was going
to be that these bees,
we're just gonna come here and outbreed
the regular bs.
And you're laughing.
Remember possible?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
There's some great movies about that to
the killer bees.
But there's no way to tell by looking at
them.
I don't know.
I don't think so.
I'm somewhat into it,
but I haven't investigated that part
yet.
So these bees that came over from the,
perhaps africanized bees that when they
killed the queen and then introduce
those bees to the rest of the bs that
everybody chill out.
Yeah.
So it was just that one crazy bitch.
Well,
yeah,
she,
you know,
she's laying the eggs.
She's passing on the whatever DNA.
Uh,
but those,
the uh,
the forager bees,
the ones that you see out and about,
they only live a month so they will die
out.
And how long did she live?
She can live between one to five years.
Wow.
What a bizarre culture.
Really,
really cool.
And without them,
I mean you're,
there's lots of,
you know,
orange almonds,
all kinds of stuff,
especially here in California and the,
you know,
in the,
uh,
in the center,
a center of California,
all that farming,
if there's no bs,
there's,
there's no fruit.
Yeah.
What a bizarre sort of symbiotic
relationship that we have with some one
weird insect pollination.
I mean,
you would have thought that that would
have been taken care of some other way
and it wouldn't be that a b has to do
it.
Well,
there are others that do it.
What,
doing butterflies and certain,
I'll tell you,
not just honey bees,
but there's,
there's probably over 3000 different
kinds of bees there.
They don't have,
they don't have a hive society like the
honeybees do,
but all these other bees are like
loners.
They live in the ground or something and
they just,
they just get enough pollen for
themselves.
So they're kind of lone lone wolves out
there.
But the honeybees are the ones that have
more of a society.
I raise chickens and um,
this chicken thing with us happened.
We just got a couple of chickens and
next thing you know we have this giant
fucking chicken house at 23 chickens and
they're running around my yard.
Is it the same way with the leg?
Just kind of like slowly step into this
and then get deeper and deeper?
Yeah,
I mean just like getting your first
tattoos,
like.
Yeah.
Wow,
that's cool.
I want more.
Right.
And uh,
yeah,
you just start to appreciate it.
I think when I come off tour it's like
my head is like ricocheting around and
there I go and I sit and watch the bees.
Just watch them go in and out,
in and out.
There's like this frigging landing strip
that he come in and they look so busy.
It relaxes me.
I know.
It's like,
wow.
Okay.
I'm not that busy.
Yeah,
just chill.
No.
Whey do you like a glass wall in any way
where you can see into the.
Have you ever seen those hives where
they make them?
Do you have it like that?
We can look in there.
Yeah.
I've got one of the.
Well,
oh that's like a display one we bring
into schools and stuff.
See I don't have one of those,
but I got a couple different kinds of
hives and it's fun to see,
you know,
sometimes you have the frames that I'm
already kind of prebuilt and then they
deposit their stuff in it or you'll
watch them grow their own comb from
nothing and it's pretty amazing.
How do you get them to stay there
though?
Like how does it work?
Like I see those boxes and I know that
bees do have hives in those boxes,
but how does it initially start?
Well,
it's the queen.
Wherever the queen is,
that's where they go.
So she decides to be in that.
So how do you get her to stay in that
box?
You have a place for her to lay eggs.
I mean that's,
that's it.
Yet.
And she will stay and if she's there,
you know when they go off to to swarm to
go find a new hive.
If you've ever seen a swarm up in a
tree,
just like a giant,
like football size or even bigger,
a shape of just bs at Queen is right in
the middle and they're all just around
her and then they send off the scouts to
find a new spot.
They come back,
say,
hey,
it's over here to do their little wiggle
dance and that shows them how to get
there and they all go there.
We had an incident one time
once on fear factor where we covered
these people with bs.
There was like a beekeeper there and he
had his hive and a local hive came over
and a group of bees came over and met
with these bees and we had to clear the
area out and they had to have a
conversation.
Literally what happened,
they were in the air just floating
around and then they worked it out and
then the Arby's came back and they went
back to the hive and their bees went
about their business.
They were just like,
what the fuck's going on?
You guys moving in here?
Like,
what are you doing?
Territorial?
Somehow or another they worked it out
though.
There was no death.
There will
be fucking braveheart war.
It just.
They figured it out at a good
negotiator.
I wonder what do they communicate with
any living they using pheromones.
Like how are they?
Smells.
Smells and dances.
Dances,
yeah.
Some B will find it.
Like,
hey man,
I found like a garden somewhere and
they'll come back and they'll see him do
the little wiggle thing.
It's like how many wiggles his way and
then they turned left and then turn that
that's,
that's like a half a mile this way and
then that,
that way.
And then they all learn it and then they
go,
hey,
I found some water.
Here's a place to go.
So they literally can tell them where
something is,
but the movements,
holy shit,
that's crazy.
So it's almost like a,
like a body language.
Pretty much.
Yep.
And they all know it somehow.
Instinctively.
Yep.
Wow.
Yeah.
It's pretty bizarre.
There's a lot,
a lot to learn about those things.
That's really bizarre.
Yeah.
I didn't know that they can tell each
other where something is just by
wiggling,
like they have like this means a mile.
That means go left.
Wow,
man.
I can get.
I'm going to get deep and bs,
man.
What the fuck have you done?
All right.
Yeah.
And there's,
I'm sure there's probably a feel of
like,
wow,
I'm,
there's a whole society right here in my
yard and I'm,
I'm overseeing it,
you know,
there's probably a sense of importance.
Uh,
but you know,
I,
I lay off him.
I mean there are people that are
checking them all the time and this and
that and oh,
you got to put the,
the like certain pads in there to kill
the Mites and you gotta do this and
that.
It's like another natural man.
They've been around longer than we have.
So just let them go.
They know what they're doing.
I don't know who's to say I know what
I'm doing with them.
Do they need specific types of plants
around them in order to survive?
Yeah.
Well,
something that they can pollinate and
you know,
it's from a,
it's good to plant,
you know what I've planned,
I planted stuff that,
you know,
okay,
it blooms in the spring and then there's
other stuff that blooms in the summer
and then there's other stuff that blooms
in the late summer so they've always got
something going on.
But they hibernate.
They hibernate in the winter.
No kidding.
Was like bears.
Yep.
So when you are in Vail and you,
uh,
you have obviously a really cold weather
in the winter,
what do they do?
They just shut down and stay in the hive
and don't move.
Well,
uh,
I don't have bees unveil yet and I'm
going to try and figure out how to do
that.
But uh,
they mean just like cattle,
you know,
your winter room down in the lowlands.
So,
uh,
I haven't found a place to,
to have bees go where there,
you know,
there's less.
No,
but I'll,
I'll figure something out because it's
something I love doing.